mais j'ai évoqué effectivement à
plusieurs reprises la question du du
smartphone et dans les études qu'on
avait menées à nouveau notamment avec
avec l'Open sur sur ces questions de de
d'usage du numérique parmi les chiffres
qui étaient sortis évidemment la place
prépondérante du smartphone du téléphone
portable et c'est vrai que je le disais
l'accès au contenu port droit cycle
cybarcellement la haine en ligne ça
passe beaucoup par le smartphone et
c'est un peu le grand absent ce projet
de loi dans la mesure où on aurait pu
imaginer un certain nombre de
dispositifs ou de mesures spécifiques à
cette question du du téléphone portable
en particulier ce constat qui est
finalement qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes
sont équipés de manière très précoce et
son voie et sont souvent équipés sur les
avec les mêmes outils que nous alors
qu'ils n'ont pas évidemment la même
capacité la même maturité pour utiliser
ces outils et donc effectivement
l'éducation l'accompagnement est
important mais c'est peut-être aussi se
réinterroger sur la place du smartphone
dans notre société sur la question de
l'autorisation l'utilisation ou
l'interdiction du smartphone chez chez
les enfants est-ce que est-ce qu'on
devrait pas aller un peu plus loin je
n'ai pas forcément de mesures concrète à
vous proposer mais c'est vrai que c'est
pour nous une préoccupation importante
de se dire que si on veut aussi lutter
contre toutes ces dérives si on veut
mieux protéger nos enfants il faut sans
doute aujourd'hui reposer la question de
notamment du smartphone qui est un objet
par nature difficile à accompagner
difficile à surveiller difficile à
encadrer
et qui et qui est laissé dans les mains
des enfants de manière très précoce et
c'est pour nous un vrai point
d'interrogation et sans doute une
réflexion à mener